I gotta ask you real quick about your
injury footage which we finally saw my
question was why didn't we see you told
me it was like a murder scene I was
looking for the blood I gotta tell you
though where was the footage of the
blood I'm like come on an iPhone someone
I know that sounds horrifying of me that
I am here with the man himself pilot
Pete Peter I have so many questions so
we're gonna dive right in let's do it
let's do it let's dive okay first one
right off the top big one I know you've
talked about this a little bit but you
and Victoria F so she wins the group
date you get the Cosmo cover and then
these modeling photos come out what was
your reaction when you saw those alleged
photos of her posing for her campaign
that used the phrase white lives matter
yeah that was um that was I was
unfortunately I was and I'm also I'm
learning about all this in real time
just like everyone else is I had no idea
about any of her involvement with any
campaign like that during our time
together dating and you know I think
it's unfortunate a lot of the headlines
have kind of been taken out of contact
with - like my support about what she
was doing and I would encourage anyone
to actually read the full article
because you know I they're in no way
support that type of campaign and I do
also feel like though its it wouldn't be
appropriate for me right now I don't
necessarily speak too much on that
without giving her a chance to address
the public and make an actual statement
and well this is somebody you knew I
mean you dated as we've seen so how has
your opinion of her changed in light of
some of what's come out yeah I mean it's
again it's unfortunate and the Victoria
that I got to know on the show I never
would have ever expected anything like
this to come out with her again I don't
know if she was fully aware of what she
was doing when she was you know I guess
modeling for that campaign I'm I've
heard some you know possible theory that
she actually didn't know what that there
was a confusion with it was like a fish
company or something but they still use
the phrase white lives matter yeah yeah
no I that's there's no defending that
there's no defending that and you know I
it's unfortunate again that she partook
in that in that type of campaign and I
think if she could do it over again she
would but I know we support that
obviously and I hope she has a chance
the public and make things right I gotta
ask you Peter there's been a lot of
reaction about your group of women
overall I don't know if you've read the
tweets but look a lot of the fan viewer
reaction is that this is maybe the
Caddy's most dramatic group of women
ever on the show
yeah what's your response to that I yeah
I would probably agree at this point
there is so much that I didn't know
obviously was going on you know when I
wasn't there when I when they were just
in there in the house by themselves when
I'd cancelled
cocktail parties and they'd have that
full on like that last confrontation
with Tammy and Sydney I think that's ah
it's a little too much and I wasn't I
didn't like to see that I really didn't
has your opinion changed of anyone
watching all this back if so good I
truly did not yeah I guess I mean I
didn't I guess I'm understanding a
little bit more of why some of the woman
acted the way they did when I was right
before I started handing out roses in
Costa Rica and then Tammy came in and
McKenna came to speak with me I had no
idea truly why they were so eager and
felt like there was so necessary for
them to to talk with me um and you know
watching that back now I understand like
that confrontation with them and Kelsey
that was insane and that was that was
like that was a little too much for me
that wasn't cool watching would you
maybe have done some things differently
and what if anything except some people
home at different times or I mean I get
yeah looking back on it now but
hindsight's 20/20 like in that moment I
only have the information that I know
right and that's the only stuff I have
going on going off of and I'm making the
best I'm not trying to make poor
decisions
yeah I'm really not the tell-alls coming
up who are you most interested to ask oh
boy that's gonna be interesting
honestly price Sydney she never came off
to me the way that I was kind of seeing
how she acted with with some of the
women you know when I wasn't there just
a little bit curious about that and that
just I guess she was kind of hiding a
personality didn't necessarily know very
well just be equally honest I had my
lunch like literally in the bathroom
stall
senior year what do you think of people
allegedly you went to high school with
her sharing these yearbook photos saying
she was a popular girl not the victim of
bullying that she claims she's defended
her story but what do you think of all
that I don't know say I think that she
was lying like what about her not going
to some of the high school dances I
believed her on that I guess some of the
pictures came out were about her just in
a beauty pageant and whatnot so listen
it's I feel like so many of us now have
been under attack I know with this show
and it's I I don't necessarily
understand why it seems like in recent
seasons like there's been so much hate
kind of coming on and that kind of
saddens me like I feel like that's not
what this is about
this is truly about trying to hopefully
have an amazing love story and it's like
being just overcome and overwhelmed
right now with all this insane drama and
all this hate and it's just it sucks but
it is what it is it's it's tough
watching it and like the way it is
there's a lot of stuff again that I
didn't know and I knew that as I was
filming that that I only had my
interactions with each of the women
that's all I could go off of but it's
tough my read on you right now is new
honestly under the surface feeder you're
a really good guy you seem a little
frustrated like I feel like you want to
kind of confront these women a little
bit yeah I I definitely feel like there
were like I said I was like deceived at
all but like it just it can feel a
little bit a little bit just I I don't
know I can I get that people can be
dramatic people can kind of be catty
sometimes but I didn't know is necessary
to that extent well you've been
criticized as being rewarding of drama
indecisive never my I understand being
indecisive because dating 30 women is
not easy and that will never be easy and
no one's prepared for that so I totally
give myself self grace for being
indecisive in a moment that's so
confusing and so tough and it's and it's
it's it's kind of rush you know you have
deadlines you have to let go of people
and that um I'm okay with by the way a
photo was surfaced of Sidney and Hannah
next to each other in high school about
their I didn't know I knew they were
both from Alabama I had no idea that
they went to same high school literally
standing next to each other any hair but
that's that's crazy I
de hann about it I haven't know but I
didn't know but I realized like I had
obviously had a thing for like Alabama
girls and yeah here we are one woman
who's caused no problems Madison yes
how are your feelings for her at this
point she's the one person who hasn't
fought with anyone else in the house or
with you so I'm thinking that I mean I
will say this there you know there is
obviously a lot of drama going on and a
lot of cattiness but I was someone that
I always was looking towards the ankle
and I knew what I wanted and you know
just because the nature of this this
whole process you have to keep so many
people around right and I never got to
down and to discourage because I knew
that I was going to be okay again
well you told me before that you were
happy with how things ended but look we
had just on Hanah season that you were
on a lot changed after filming it so
right are you still happy with how
things ended I am okay yeah I can say I
followed my heart the entire time it was
this was the hardest experience of my
entire life I am still so grateful for
it and I really would do it again I
promise you I would I know right now
it's like a lot of stuff going on but I
totally would and I can say I'm happy
and I follow my heart are we going to
see a situation like a Hannah or an Ari
where things change after the final
moment that big final moment looks huge
right yeah I definitely think my the
ending of mine is very unique so I'm not
saying it's gonna be similar to any of
the previous seasons but is it really
over I don't try here's the thing Peter
all my love there's a lot of
flip-flopping that's happened I never
know who your front-runner is you change
every week so I'm sitting here thinking
we've seen things and differently on the
show before could it happen I promise
you my frontrunner did not stop changing
after about week four and whether how
that's shown you know the show does a
really good job of you know it's very
entertaining but I promise you my
frontrunner did not change and leave it
at that okay I gotta ask you real quick
about your injury footage which we
finally saw my question was why didn't
we see you told me it was like a murder
scene I was looking for the blood I
gotta tell you know where it was the
footage of the blood I'm like oh
found someone I know that sounds
horrifying of me that I yeah that's good
actually that's gruesome but no it truly
was that the only footage we had was
that grainy Hotel footage that's
literally the cameras we weren't rolling
at all we just finished doing some
b-roll so I was I was kind of happy they
even showed that part I thought cameras
would come to the hospital yeah well no
we had read like two and half hours like
we were in the middle of the jungle and
you're holding here like there's like a
world war two big thing I was that's a
little scary okay real quick you got
chase Rice's phone number did you ever
text him or call him about all this
victorious done no I did and that was
obviously very weird and uncomfortable
that I put my biggest dummy talking to
him and like watching me like playback
or watching that play that I sing at our
wedding I know that was so good you